a bowl of ramen is made of six things
noodles oils
toppings tare
soup and thyme
it's difficult for all six of those to
be put together so when you eat a bowl
of ramen with all six of those elements
in perfect balance it really touches
your soul and takes you to a magical
place
my name is kezo shimamoto and i love
ramen
i've been making it for over 10 years
and i've probably eaten over 10 000
bowls in my life
[Music]
started making ramen 10 years ago in
japan
i moved to new york and created the
ramen burger and that sort of went into
the creation of ramen shack we wheeled
it out every weekend just to serve ramen
for one day
after ramen shaq closed the oldest
existing ramen shop in new york city
rairai can ask me to do a one-time
special dinner and i jumped at the
opportunity
the dinner is five days away but the
amount of time that goes into that i
mean we're talking 400 bowls for one
dinner
there is a lot of work to do
it's going to take me five days to prep
for this dinner
the first element of ramen is noodles
for the noodles we start with the water
and concert so kansoi is the type of
salt that really adds that firm
springiness that you get with a ramen
noodle for my recipe of my noodles i
combine a blend of three or four
different flowers
and put in a little egg powder and just
put it in the mixer and just let it run
ramen noodles have such a low percentage
of water a couple drops of water can
change everything
although the machine is mixing the flour
like i'm still using all my senses to
really check and see if it's forming
i'll touch it i'll feel it i'll squeeze
it
playing with the dough is almost like
playing with wet sand at the beach
[Music]
so we lift up the mixer and start
putting it through the machine and make
sheets
this process is pretty dangerous you
have these big rollers that are heavy
this
is probably the most important part of
having a machine do it rather than doing
it by hand because it allows you to make
more portions faster and efficiently so
when we take the first sheet and we
split it into two and then we put it
through the machine again that's the
kneading process i always watch and
stare at all these rolls because it's
it's kind of soothing it's it's almost
like my therapy
we let it rest for at least 30 minutes
after that we stretch out the dough
we
incrementally
adjust the width of the roller to press
it and thin it out
as the sheet gets rolled thinner it
passes through the cutter which creates
our ramen noodles
and as the noodle comes down there's
certain timing it gets cut and you have
to catch it roll it put it in the case
and then every so often you also have to
weigh it because we want to be have it a
consistent portion so it's a very
rhythmic job you can get ahead of
yourself and start dropping noodles so
you really have to find that rhythm and
just work to the beat
[Music]
so now that the noodles are done we'll
just let them rest until the day of the
event
in japanese there's a term called nekaru
which means to sleep so when the noodles
sleep then they just get better just
like humans
the second element of ramen is infused
oils
for one of my ramen bowls i will be
making a neboshi infused oil so niboshi
is the dried sardine or dried anchovy i
would take off the heads the guts will
get thrown out the body will go into my
dashi and the heads will be used in my
niboshi oil so we got to bring the oil
up put the scallions in first the
scallions have water in them so it
really kind of makes this explosion
so it's very dangerous and you gotta be
careful then we add the niboshi heads
and we wait until it
gets a brownish coloring there is a
definitely a certain point
if you start to smell it you start to
see the change that's when you know it's
done
the third element of ramen is toppings
i'm actually going to be serving eight
different bowls of ramen so there's a
lot of different toppings that go into
these the chashu is definitely probably
the most common topping in ramen i think
i'm making about a hundred pounds of
chashu just for this event so the pork
belly comes in a slab each fourth will
get rolled and used
with any type of raw meat you have your
warm hands touching it and there's
possibility of it spoiling so it's best
to go as fast as you can i'm four times
as fast as i used to be when i started
it really helps because
like being fast but also being
good at what you're doing is key
so after i roll them we
boil them in just hot water that takes
out all the impurities of the pork once
we boil them then we take them out and
then boil them separately in a soy sauce
marinade and we basically just let it
sit in there overnight
another topping that i have to prep is
menma bamboo shoot so after a quick
rinse i
lay them out inside a container it's
important to me that they're straight
because then they can bring a nice
symmetry to the bowl
so then i put the marinade in which is a
blend of soy sauce and sugars and
meating
and sake so the mema is cold but this
marinade goes in hot it allows the mamma
to soak it up immediately by the time of
the event the memo will taste
perfect by the time the day is over i've
made all the noodles for 400 servings
about 100 pounds of pork belly
and it's still only just half the
toppings so i still have a lot of work
to do tomorrow
all right it's day two the first thing
we'll do is check on the pork
so when i start taking them out i'm
looking for the right color that dark
soy sauce color really smell the chashu
smells amazing it's like a meat mount
fuji
after the pork belly chills for a bit we
then cut them into slices so when i cut
it and it's got that perfectly round
spiral shape and you get a little bit of
a pinkish color that's really what i'm
looking for so at the event i'm going to
torch it but for right now i'll set them
aside in the fridge
now i'm going to start working on my
eggs
so poking a hole in the egg also will
release any trapped air inside so that
air being released will make the egg
become
more a perfect egg shape once the water
comes to a boil i'll insert all the eggs
and i end up stirring it for the first
minute or so because it lets the trapped
air come out from the egg and also it
will center the yolk at the seven minute
mark we shock them in ice water and this
allows the cooking process to stop i
want to go as fast as possible but at
the same time i don't want to break the
eggs after i peel all the eggs they go
into
another marinade
of soy sauce and sugar and meating then
they'll sit for a few days up until the
day of the event
so the last topping that i'll make today
is the spinach so it's important to
wring out all the water because when i
put the spinach onto my bowl of ramen i
want the spinach to absorb the flavor of
the soup rather than the reverse if you
go too fast then you might damage the
spinach
i'm making a ton of toppings
for my bowl of ramen but every single
topping has an important purpose
narita is a critical piece because
naruto tells the customer this is ramen
so after all my toppings it's time to
work on another important part the
fourth element of ramen is the soup soup
is like the soul
of the bowl
and i start off with the pork feet and
pork backbone and i'll cook those first
so once those finish cooking i'll add
chicken back chicken feet and also i'll
put in a bunch of different vegetables
from potato to ginger to onion and all
of this is is happening
in a big pot and i'm letting it get
thicker and thicker
once those are all boiled together i'll
take a giant whisk and i'll attach it to
my drill and i'll just blend it for a
few minutes just to get a nice creamy
texture and break down all the bones
straining it definitely is the longest
process like you have to sift it by hand
one or two scoops at a time because it's
almost cement like
and you have to guide it through the
strainer gravity won't help at this
point so by the time this soup is done i
mean it's very thick but it's also very
flavorful this soup has 13 ingredients
and takes over six hours to make if you
add that up to all the other toppings
and all the other prep this bowl of
ramen will have 100 ingredients and 100
hours of work put into it i hope people
are going to like it
today's the big day and i've definitely
been looking forward to this day
[Music]
i couldn't sleep much because i spent a
lot of time visualizing serving all 400
bowls
so when we first arrived i just unloaded
everything checking out their their
noodle boiler the candy stoves and over
the weekend i also finished prepping all
the other toppings for the other bowls
the fifth element of ramen is the tare
flavoring and i actually made that a few
weeks ago because it takes a long time
to mature
the challenges of a pop-up is definitely
cooking in a space that's not yours so
it's really just trying to fit my puzzle
into theirs
even though i've prepared all my food
and all my ingredients i still need to
know how to prepare my ramen with their
equipment so for this event you know i
have a few former staff coming to help
out but i also have some ramen fans from
around the country that just want to
work there's a guy from austin texas a
guy from cincinnati ohio a guy from
providence rhode island and a guy from
washington dc to
have so much passion around a dish and
fly from around the country i think
it's amazing
all right guys november 12th it's been
seven and a half months since ramen shaq
closed i mean everyone misses it i miss
it and going to be very special it might
get crazy but let's just enjoy it and
we've got about 400 portions i think so
let's try and sell out we got already a
line out the door
let's just have fun enjoy it and eat
good ramen feed good ramen to these
people
and
i guess that's it let's go
one two three
[Applause]
[Music]
the moment the door is open it took less
than a minute for the whole shop to be
filled
just knowing that the people want ramen
shack
it's it's a good feeling
the first order came in and it was for
my classic shoyu when we make a bowl of
ramen for service each bowl has a
certain order that needs to be followed
and this is where the final
sixth element timing comes into play
i'll start by heating up the bowl as the
bowl is heating i'll start warming up
the soup so i have a certain amount of
time to do things in between then before
i start with the tare i'll drop the
noodles the noodles take about a minute
and within that minute i want to finish
up putting in the tare the oils the
black pepper and the yuzu juice once
that's done the soup will be hot enough
to pour into the bowl the second that
that minute is up i take the noodles out
of the boiler and i let it sit there for
a while so all the water drains out and
then i'll start shaking it
if that water is left in the noodle and
you put it into your soup it'll dilute
the flavor so you don't want that
[Music]
starting now we have one minute to get
this bowl in front of the customer and
you need to fold the noodle to give it a
plating surface otherwise the toppings
could sink in and you might not see them
we place the chashu mama and spinach
then the naruto and the nori and the egg
[Music]
the noodles will start to change texture
the longer you leave it sitting so we
want it to get to the customer while it
still tastes good
after the first bowl
every order that comes in it just starts
to become a dance
soup
noodles topping
soup
noodles
topping
grabbing a bowl putting soup putting the
noodles like it's just repeated over and
over again
like it's organized chaos of a ramen
shop
i love it
one of the bowls i'm serving is a
different variation of ramen called
tsukemen it's a thicker noodle that
cooks for seven minutes and then it gets
rinsed and shocked in cold water then
plated separately from the ganja broth
and the ganja broth is a whole different
story the noodles and the broth are
separate and the noodles are actually
cold
and you dip them in a hot soup
[Music]
four hours in was still
pretty intense like the crowd was
getting bigger it's below freezing
outside the weight was like three or
four hours to get a bowl crazy like even
though you're tired you know you're
hungry you're thirsty you want to use
the bathroom but i seen all these
familiar faces and people enjoying
having ramen shack back for one night
that's what keeps you going
each bowl has its own personality
i'm sort of giving birth to that bowl
and letting it become one with the
customer
as the bowl starts to assemble itself
piece by piece
it comes alive
[Music]
we anticipated closing at 10 p.m and
getting that last order out i think it
was already past 11 p.m
for the first time in eight hours i
could finally take a rest
my team was very hungry they couldn't
eat because we were busy and i was able
to cook a bowl
for each member of my team
to see their faces after working so hard
that was
pretty special
[Music]
if i had a chance to bring back the
ramen shack with these people then i
would do it in a heartbeat
[Music]
the final bowl of the night was for me
and it was actually the bowl that was on
the secret menu called jedi again
that final bowl felt like the last 10
years were worth it
today is also my birthday
i spent the day cooking and eating ramen
and i really couldn't imagine it being
any better than that
[Music]
[Music]
you